[Musique]
c'est ed
m
[Musique]
ok donc jeu on avait les uns elle est où
elle et son livre souligne cette appli
taxi la wii ils doivent être en bas
génial oh [ __ ] j'ai une contraction
même les clés total
bonjour monsieur ben c'est ça bonjour
monsieur vous payez vous je vais
accoucher a eu un petit souci c'est que
j'ai nettoyé les photos vous avez nous
emmener à l'hôpital immédiatement sinon
je vous mets zéro étoile il vous faut un
bon ben ok ok ok ok pas de souci est pas
tout si on y va
[Musique]
messieurs vous pouvez prendre la rocade
là ouais si vous vous lassez si vous
avez des favoris pour les meulières dès
le début j'aurais pu
bonjour quand vous sentez vous très bien
merci docteur je parle à vous de faire
ici à moi qui vous ont prolongé vous je
viens ici l'ouverture de votre colle et
hockey que tim est bon ça va lui
[Musique]
allez c'est bien on pousse on pousse
heures vous qui allez ont poussé mal
non mais j'en ai rarement
qu'avez-vous dit m me voir je vois ses
fesses quoi bon il est ancien je veux
dire il se passe quoi la docteure la bbc
retourner la dernière minute c'est rare
mais ça arrive on va partir sur une
petite césarienne
non non non non isolé mais c'est ce qui
est plus prudent nous emmener au bloc je
veux je veux pas de césarienne c'est
impossible c'est pas possible je vais
lui parler je lui parle elle est celle
de plenty tard la bouche tu es petit tu
fais allez hop on verrait mal perçue
mais on va quand même vous emmener au
blanc non non non a ajouté m
[Musique]
ah le bébé à bouger la tête vers le bas
pour pouvoir le faire sortir
faymann a poussés à aller vous allez
c'est bon pour la tête
voilà sept ans que l on y est presque on
dit allez j'espère la toupie comme on
appris à l'elysée
[Musique]
elle et ses beautés